a good editor must have some sense of
how to tell a story and that involves a
sense of rhythm and it's a little bit
like telling a good joke if the joke is
could be the joke could be a great joke
but if you tell it with the wrong rhythm
it falls flat
so there's us there's a in there's an
inbuilt relationship between the story
itself and how to tell a story and the
rhythm with which you tell it and
editing is certainly seventy percent
about rhythm and what you are showing
and the rate at which you show it and
it's it's very hard to teach this you
you in a sense it's like dance you can
explain the rudiments of dance but to
really learn how to dance you have to
dance you can just have to get out there
and do it and you feel awkward at the
beginning naturally but then you
gradually figure out well I'll put my
foot here and then I do this little
thing and that gets me over there and
the editing is very similar to dance in
that way in the sense that you can think
of the architecture of a film as a kind
of frozen dance and what we do in
assembling the film for the first time
and then refining it is gradually
improving the the basic structure and
then the finer details of that of those
rhythms
the the assistant is somebody ideally
who is very well balanced between the
let's call it the decimal points and the
big picture it's very easy to get lost
in the in the decimal points they've
defined things but if you're not aware
of the larger picture of what does the
story need what does the editor need
what what's the mood of things today on
a kind of human level the assistant has
to be tuned into that but not get so
fascinated with that that they lose
touch with getting that all of the the
zeros in order all of the there's a lot
of number crunching now especially with
digital work it's it can get very
inhuman at times and you have to balance
that with the human aspects of it
one of the big shifts that's happened
recently is obviously digital camp
cameras that capture the image digitally
but also the the digital chip that is
recording these is getting bigger and
bigger and so we're dealing with image
density pixel density that's huge
compared to what it was even five years
ago or certainly 10 years ago what this
allows us to do
editorially is recompose the image
within the frame and it's very useful in
a documentary because when you're
shooting a documentary you don't know
where this particular moment is going to
go in the film how it's going to
integrate and so there may be things
within the frame that ultimately will
not fit within the story and so the
ability to recompose to to enlarge the
frame and omit something that is now
incorrect
perhaps a character who has disappeared
from the film is in this shot well we
can just eliminate that character by
narrowing the field and we used to not
be able to do that so freely because a
it was expensive and be even if you
could do it the the grain structure of
film was such that it now you knew
something had happened to this shot
whereas with digital film it's not clear
that that's the case so we can in a
sense photograph the film a second time
in the editing by recomposing within the
within the frame in a sense if you if
you think of normal editing it's
horizontal one shot after the other like
a row of cars and a train the this kind
of editing I'm talking about is vertical
editing where you're editing within the
frame and choosing to see or not see
certain things in the original
photography
well I think the best thing you can do
as an editor who is trying to learn how
to edit is to edit and in that sense
people today are in a much better
position than we were 50 years ago
because then film was very expensive and
the machines on which we could edit film
were very expensive and it was just hard
to find the time and the resources to to
get your hands on the stuff now the
Internet is just overloaded with
material that you can download or you
can shoot it yourself on a
point-and-shoot camera and you can get
free editing software that allows you to
edit and do very complicated things with
sound but we could not dream of and so
it's as I was saying earlier the the
thing about learning how to dance is to
dance to actually do it and that's true
in this case obviously look at as many
films as you can and see how it has been
done and then forge your own path
because you will discover your own way
of putting these things together this is
a very new art in human experience it's
it's barely a hundred years old whereas
all the other arts their origins are
lost in prehistory and so we're we
individually and we culturally are
discovering how to do this and there's
lots more to discover